The next question was about handling the final slash because
it's technically a different URL and what the best way to handle that is.
Ending URLs in slash--honestly, I don't know the correct answer.
I usually make my websites not care.
You've seen in my URL mapping I have a regular expression that looks like this--/blog/?.
And what this basically says is this will map the URL/blog,
and then it will also match it that has the trailing slash, which I think it's what most friendly way to do it,
because some browsers will automatically add the slash or users will add a slash.
They have a way of creeping up, and you don't want to have like /blogwork/44 or vice versa
because you make a lot of people hates it, so I just make it optional.
Now, you can do this thing--sometimes, and I've been working on this on the final project
where the URLs are going to be a little bit more dynamic.
I usually have regular a expression that looks something like this:
/+ or it's like .../+ or // or something like that.
Basically, I detect the situation where URL ends in a bunch of slashes.
And then I have this go to some handler that automatically redirects with single-slash version
or redirects to a zero-slash version.
Depending on your websites, that's kind of handy.
The question that somebody asked, they basically proposed,
"Should I do it this way? or "Should I have a redirect way?.
The answer is, it depends on web app.
Do whatever feels right, but it's a great question to ask, because it is something you should think about.
You should try to make both versions work.
It could be the case that /blog is the blog and / has got more content.
It's kind of a hierarchical view your website--that's fine--but think about it, and it is pretty easy.
Generally, you just add a question mark and forget about it. I hope that helps.